qui vient à silaos passe obligatoirement
par la rue du pèrebiteau c'est en effet
l'artère principale qui se faile de
l'entrée au centre-ville la mairie la
poste et de nombreux commercial de part
et d'autre l'église en marque émité
estce le chemin du souvenir du père
boitaure boau non ça rien du
tout
HABA
c'est une véritable vocation qui conduit
Paul boîau à consacrer sa vie à la
paroisse de
silaos néomand en 1901 paul Antoine
Julien boîau suit des études secondaires
au séminaire il choisit ensuite la
Congrégation du Saint-Esprit qui
correspond à sa volonté d'assurer les
missions les plus pénibles et de
s'occuper des âmes
délaissées après son ovicia et son
service militaire il est ordonné prêtre
à 23 ans malgré sa santé fragile les
spiritin accepte de l'envoyer outre mer
en
1927 dès 1928 il encadre le petit
séminaire de
silaos un établissement catholique qui
accompagne certains au sacerdocce mais
qui est surtout réputé pour la qualité
de son
enseignement puis il succède au Père
mage comme curé de
silaos c'est le père boitau qui lance la
construction de l'église en
1937 infatigable il parcours le CIRC à
pied de palmiste rougge à brassc de la
Rivière Saint-Louis à
silaos sa santé décline lorsque les
prêtres du Séminaire viennent le soigner
il découvre que le père vit dans le
dénuement le plus total il n'a ni
manteau ni chandail mais une collection
d'instruments de pénitence caché une
ceinture de barbelé une corde tachée de
sang un collier garni de pointe le père
Boiteau r lâ à 46
ans